歡迎收看本週的泛科學新聞
這是泛科學新聞第 39 集
首先我要真誠地感謝
新加入的 100 位泛糰會員
因為有你們這些「想開了」的乾媽乾爹
才容得下我們這些「想不開」的乾女兒乾兒子
繼續在這裡把科學傳播做得更好
Cảm ơn sự ủng hộ của bạn.
來到本季倒數第二集
誠摯希望還在考慮加入會員的你把握時間
因為你把握的不是你的時間
而是我們的時間
希望明年還有機會能繼續維持節目的製作
在動盪不安的世界中
讓我們陪著你把動盪當點心
把不安當調味料
大口大口吃掉
現在就點擊下方的加入按鈕
快點 我等你
你以為躲在家裡就能避開污染嗎
科學家發現你家可能比外頭還要毒
蛤
大膽一點把可能去掉
誒 不是 你這樣我講不下去
根據剛發表在《PNAS Nexus》上的研究
史丹佛大學領導的研究團隊
揭開了那個藏在許多人家廚房的「特級咒靈」
別怕
不是黑沐死 是瓦斯彈
戶外空污有政府監測
但我們花更長時間待的家裡呢
可是科學家也沒辦法一家一家裝感測器
所以他們直接在電腦裡
打造了一個全美國規模的《模擬市民》
首先他們利用 EULP
終端使用負載曲線資料庫
也就是全美房屋的「數位權狀」
知道每一戶人家是透天還是公寓
哪一年蓋的、有沒有中央空調等等
精選出 24 種經典格局
為 1.33 億棟房子建立了「數位替身」
然後匯入大量行為數據
設定成千上萬種生活劇本
這模擬細到連晚餐是大火煎牛排
還是小火煮水餃、抽油煙機有沒有開
甚至是不是天氣太冷 死不開窗
通通都算進去了
這些房子跟劇本被丟進 NIST
美國國家標準暨技術研究院開發的
CONTAM 模型
這是一個空氣流體力學的「物理引擎」
能精確計算廢氣怎麼從廚房飄過走廊
最後毒死那個在馬桶上滑手機的
接下來關鍵的一步是「地圖掛鉤」
將模擬結果對應到全美每個郵遞區號的
戶外空氣數據
這是為了要算無遺漏
得出「總暴露量」
把吸進去的「戶外廢氣」和「室內廢氣」分開
抓出真正的兇手
經過 51,840 種平行宇宙模擬
以及外加 10000 次的蒙地卡羅隨機變數模擬
結果發現
敵人就在瓦斯爐
對於瓦斯爐用戶
這個裝置平均貢獻了
整天吸入二氧化氮 (NO2) 總量的 25%
如果是那種天天大火快炒的前 5% 重度使用者
瓦斯爐貢獻的毒氣
更直接超過總暴露量的一半
其實先前研究就發現瓦斯爐
是違反 WHO 空氣品質指引（100 ppb）的慣犯
超過 99% 的室內二氧化氮「急性超標」
都是它搞的鬼
也就是說用電磁爐或 IH 爐的家庭
室內空氣基本上是純潔的
根本不會發生這種急性中毒
蛤
對 CORTIS 急性中毒怎麼辦
那種沒救
很多人買清淨機防堵外面 PM2.5
轉頭卻打開瓦斯爐把家裡變成毒氣室
模型推算
如果全美瓦斯爐用戶都轉成「電氣系」
2200 萬人的二氧化氮暴露量
將會瞬間下降 安全達標
Watch me go, go, go, go, go, go.
雖然這項模擬研究只負責算出「濃度」
並沒有直接測量對健康的影響
但醫學界早就證實
NO2 是引發氣喘與呼吸道疾病的元兇
而且別忘了瓦斯爐除了 NO2
還附贈一級致癌物「苯」、甲醛、一氧化碳
和超細懸浮微粒
就像點了快樂兒童餐附贈的玩具
卻是安娜貝爾好像踏著屎（ta̍h-tio̍h sái）
雖然這是美國研究
但為了肺著想
煮飯記得窗戶全開、抽油煙機開最強
或者乾脆換成 IH 爐
誒 身為 YouTuber
當然接下來就是要推薦你一款
最新的
蛤
沒有廠商找我們業配啊
那你們繼續吸好了
科學家發現義大利人不只對披薩上
可以加什麼很嚴格
還把熊變成了狗
他們在過去兩千年間
進行了一場超大規模的生物實驗
把當地的棕熊變成了「大狗狗」
這故事剛刊登在《分子生物學與演化》期刊
主角是「亞平寧棕熊」(Apennine Brown Bear,ABB)
住在義大利中部
大概只剩下 50 幾隻極度瀕危
科學家一直覺得這群熊很奇怪
比起歐洲親戚
這群義大利熊特別小隻
頭骨形狀不一樣
最重要的是
牠們異常「溫馴」甚至有點「社恐」
對人能避就避
就算不小心遇到也傾向退縮
攻擊性明顯較低
起碼哪些活下來的人是這麼說的
這群熊是怎麼回事
難道是嚐過絕天狼拔刀牙的厲害
還是吃了太多的義大利麵呢
為了搞懂這件事
來自義大利費拉拉大學 (University of Ferrara)
等多國團隊
找了隻母熊 Lauretta
利用最新的 PacBio 長讀取技術
加上 Hi-C 染色體構象捕獲技術
組裝出高畫質基因體地圖
這就像是把 360p 畫質的錄影帶
來個 4K 數位修復
接著研究團隊利用
RAISD、XP-CLR 和 PBS 三種演算法
把這群義大利熊的基因拿去跟
斯洛伐克的棕熊、美國的灰熊交叉比對
發現亞平寧棕熊大概在 2000 到 3000 年前
就跟其他歐洲親戚分家了
而且從羅馬帝國時期開始
就處於「完全隔離」的狀態
這很誇張
也就是說兩千多年來
這群熊一直被困在義大利半島上
跟人類玩大逃殺
而羅馬人通常對鄰居不太友善
他們不斷砍伐森林、擴張農田
而且會針對性地獵殺那些
「比較兇」、「比較大隻」的熊
那麼能活下來傳宗接代的熊是哪一種
沒錯 就是膽小、怕事、見人就躲
基因裡寫著「我就爛」的熊
科學家找出了 566 個
留下演化篩選痕跡的基因
其中有一組基因特別眼熟
叫做「威廉氏症候群」(Williams-Beuren Syndrome)
相關基因
在人類醫學上威廉氏症候群的患者
會出現極度的「過度友善」 和社交渴望
科學家以前就在狗狗身上
發現過這組基因變異
這被認為是狼被馴化成狗的關鍵原因之一
另外還有像 DCC、NUMB 以及 SLC13A5等
跟神經系統發育有關的基因
也都出現了變異
意味著這些熊的大腦迴路
可能真的被改寫了
所以義大利人透過兩千年的獵殺
無意間篩選出了這群帶有
「乖狗狗基因」的低聲下氣熊
這在演化生物學上
叫做「自我馴化」(Self-domestication)
但這是有巨大代價的
研究發現因長期隔離且族群小
這群亞平寧棕熊的基因體裡
有超過 66% 的區域
是「純合子長片段」(Runs of Homozygosity, ROH)
欸 這非常可怕
就像坦格利安家族血統純正
但是遺傳疾病的風險超高
基因庫非常脆弱
科學家甚至發現牠們身上累積了
比普通熊更多的「有害基因變異」
只是剛好還能活著而已
所以如果你去義大利在森林裡
看到一隻小號的棕熊
對你露出「營業用笑容」
而且唱著 Eat it up, eat it, eat it. up
你的義大利麵可能加到錯的蘑菇了
你可能也被警告過千萬別拿腦袋去撞牆
因為大腦神經元死一個少一個絕不再生
但發表在神經科學期刊上的最新研究
可能會讓腦子有洞的你燃起希望
故事從美國約翰霍普金斯大學的一場
殘酷實驗開始
團隊為了模擬人類的創傷性腦損傷
讓一群小鼠體驗了嚴重的腦震盪
造成視網膜通往大腦上丘的線路
大約有 50% 直接斷線
照傳統觀念
這些老鼠將在模糊的世界度過餘生
但科學家懷疑事情沒那麼簡單
對 科學家總是懷疑事情沒那麼簡單
他們先用
傳統的 CTB 霍亂毒素 B 次單元追蹤劑
這就像是幫神經線路染上顏料
看看斷了多少
結果顯示受傷後一週
線路確實少了一半
但 CTB 就像紋身貼紙過兩週就淡了
沒辦法長期追蹤
於是科學家改用更狠的
AAV 腺相關病毒基因標記技術
比較起來這可是永久的基因刺青
他們設計了兩種病毒載體
一種會讓神經纖維
也就是軸突發出紅色螢光（tdTomato）
代表電線
另一種則會讓神經末梢的突觸點
發出綠色螢光（SypGFP）代表插頭
接下來就是見證奇蹟的一刻
雖然一半神經元陣亡
但活下來的那一半開始瘋狂 Carry 全場
啟動「側枝發芽」模式
從原本的軸突長出額外分支
並重新裝上突觸
硬是把斷掉的連接點補上
就像是磊札打躲避球
隊友倒一半 他不演了
一個人操控好幾隻念獸去補位
但線接上了不代表會通啊
科學家也沒那麼好騙
又用了兩招來驗證
第一招是跨突觸病毒追蹤
這是一種能跳過突觸的病毒
如果它能從眼睛跳到大腦的神經元身上發光
就代表這條路是真的接通了
第二招是 c-Fos 蛋白監測
這蛋白就像是神經元上班的打卡證明
他們把老鼠關在暗房再突然開燈
不是要祝它生日快樂
而是觀察大腦視覺區
有沒有因為光刺激而產生 c-Fos 反應
結果顯示 通了
真的通了
視覺功能真的恢復了
但但但
研究發現這回復術男女有別
公老鼠在受傷後 14 天
線路就修得跟沒受傷一樣
但母老鼠到了第 56 天進度條還在卡頓
甚至有些地方根本放棄治療
這符合了過往醫學上
發現女性腦震盪後的症狀
往往更嚴重、康復更慢
這現象可能不是心理作用
而是男女腦袋裡的硬體修復機制
真的不一樣
總之我們的大腦其實蠻 Tough
科學家下一步就是要搞清楚
為什麼男女有別
希望能開發出
讓女生也能加速修復的特效藥
但當然是從一開始就保護好腦袋最好啦
身為 YouTuber 當然接下來就是要推薦一款
最護腦的
蛤
還是沒有廠商找我們業配啊
那就多看泛科學就好
欸
你在山上如果看到紅衣小女孩
我是說這種紅紅的、吃了好像會變大的蘑菇
千萬別亂採
因為它不是菇 而是蛇菰
雖然唸起來都是ㄍㄨ
但它是植物
而且完全奉行
「阿姨我不想努力了」的人生哲學
沒有葉綠素、不行光合作用
連像樣的根都沒有
一輩子把身體插在別人的樹根上
當個徹底的寄生仔
但問題來了
既然蛇菰已經躺平了一億年
那它體內原本負責光合作用的「葉綠體」
現在成了什麼樣的演化廢墟
為了破這樁演化史上的懸案
來自沖繩科學技術大學院大學、神戶大學
以及臺北市立大學的團隊
展開了一場橫跨
臺灣、沖繩與日本本州和九州的
基因大搜查
這研究開局就很硬
因為蛇菰只生長在特定深山
菜市場沒有賣
團隊只得像在開《薩爾達》地圖一樣
跑遍東亞島鏈
採集了 7 個物種、12 個族群
這是目前對蛇菰屬最完整的一次取樣
接下來問題更麻煩
蛇菰是寄生植物
組織裡混著自己的 DNA、宿主的 DNA
還有一堆環境細菌的 DNA
是一鍋基因菜尾湯（tshài-bué thng）
為了從這堆碎片中把蛇菰的基因拼回來
研究團隊動用了次世代定序
把珍貴樣本用液態氮磨碎
提取出 DNA 跟 RNA
然後丟進機器裡產生大量短讀序
再用專門工具
如 NOVOPlasty 跟 SPAdes
重建它殘破不堪
曾經是葉綠體的質體基因體和轉錄體
這拼完還不夠
他們還得確認
這個已經不進行光合作用的廢棄工廠
還有沒有在運作
關鍵證據就是「轉運肽」（Transit peptide）
這就像是蛋白質的外送訂單地址
我們知道植物細胞的細胞核是總部
而葉綠體是代工廠
而代工廠裡頭的機器也就是蛋白質
其實是總部製造的
因此在送到葉綠體之前
會在上頭貼一個標籤
告訴物流系統送去哪
邏輯很簡單
如果代工廠已經荒廢了
總部是不會傻傻浪費資源
製造這些貼著「去葉綠體」的蛋白質的
科學家於是用上深度學習工具 DeepLoc 2.0
它可以預測每個蛋白質的轉運目的地
沒想到一般植物的質體基因體大約 150 kb
蛇菰卻被刪到只剩 14–16 kb
極致精簡到像把 Windows 刪到
只剩記事本跟踩地雷
但更扯的是 DeepLoc 分析顯示
細胞核每天仍然把超過 800 種蛋白質
送進這座「廢棄工廠」
進一步分析發現蛇菰的質體
仍負責製造脂肪酸、維生素 B2、
血紅素和多種胺基酸
厲害的泛糰可能發現了
這狀況跟瘧原蟲很相似
沒錯 瘧原蟲的祖先原本也會行光合作用
後來變成寄生蟲後
砍掉光合作用
只留下退化質體負責關鍵代謝
唉
原來蛇菰是植物界不回頭的浪子
跟寄生原生生物走一樣的路
還沒完
研究還同時解開了它怎麼傳宗接代的謎題
系統發育分析顯示
臺灣與日本島嶼上的多個蛇菰物種
各自獨立演化出「專性無融合生殖」
他們不需要受精自己就能生種子
就算孤零零漂到島上一株蛇菰不用等花粉
就能影分身殖民全島
所以蛇菰雖然看起來像菇
唸起來也像菇
真面目卻是一本「演化斷捨離」教科書
教我們孤單也有孤單的活法
所以如果你也感到孤單
不要難過
搬到深山裡吧
現在讓所有衛星操作員去放個假
那麼只要 67.2 個小時
也就是不到三天
我們的近地軌道
就會發生災難性的連環車禍
如果你覺得臺灣的交通很
嗯
那我得告訴你天上的交通更是「絕命終結站」
最近發表在 arXiv 上的一篇論文
標題很嗆
叫做「軌道上的紙牌屋（An Orbital House of Cards）」
普林斯頓大學和英屬哥倫比亞大學的科學家
開發了一個全新的驚悚指數
叫做「CRASH Clock」
全名是「碰撞實現與重大危害時鐘」
這時鐘不是拿來看幾點
而是拿來看我們離死期還有多遠
這怎麼算的
科學家特別挑了兩個時間點來 PK
一個是「巨型星座時代」還沒降臨的 2018 年
那時候馬斯克還沒把天空當成水餃鍋在下
另一個是論文撰寫時的 2025 年 6 月
差不多已經塞好塞滿
他們根據真實的衛星軌道數據
把地球外面的太空像切洋蔥一樣
切成一層一層厚度一公里的球殼
去算這些洋蔥皮裡面的「衛星密度」
發現在某些巨型星座
最密集的 550 公里高度
平均每 11 分鐘就有兩個物體
在距離不到一公里的地方擦肩而過
這就像在玩地獄難度的《天天過馬路》
不能接關
而且玩一次要幾百萬美金
接著科學家開啟了一個「殭屍模式」
模擬如果因為某種原因
所有衛星都停止「閃避」
也就是大家都不躲了直直撞過去
那第一場災難性碰撞要多久會發生
如果在還沒有那麼多低軌衛星的 2018 年
這個時間是 121 天
也就是說就算大家集體斷線
我們還有四個月可以救
但在 2025 年的現在這個數字是
2.8 天
對
連假還沒放完 天就塌了
這意味著只要衛星系統癱瘓
就有極高的機率發生碰撞
而且只要失控 24 小時
碰撞機率就高達 30%
你可能會問
那衛星好端端的幹嘛不閃
又不是用了時間停止器
對
但有個同樣恐怖的東西
就是太陽風暴
論文特別提到了
2024 年 5 月的「Gannon 風暴」
先說這跟薩爾達傳說的反派無關
任天堂法務部表示遺憾
這種強烈的太陽風暴會加熱大氣層
讓大氣膨脹
導致低軌道衛星的空氣阻力突然暴增
這時候衛星會發生兩件事
第一因為阻力變大 位置會亂飄
導航系統會抓不準它在哪
第二通訊系統可能會被太陽風暴癱瘓
這時畫風一變
上演玩命關頭 Starlink 碰碰車
一旦發生第一次碰撞
就會產生大量碎片
雖然這不一定會馬上變成那種
要幾十年才會成形的「凱斯勒效應」
但這會是一個瞬間崩塌的「紙牌屋」
我們可能在幾天內
就失去對某個軌道層的使用權
以前我們覺得太空很大丟點垃圾沒關係
現在看來只要太陽稍微打個噴嚏
我們精心打造的太空網路或太空算力中心
可能在三天內變成一堆飄浮的廢鐵
科學家發明這個 CRASH Clock
就是要警告我們
現在的太空環境已經脆弱到沒有「容錯率」了
痾 那該怎麼辦呢
道理很簡單
就是不要再繼續像下水餃那樣發衛星了
或是把東西做小一點、更好回收
另外我們也需要更即時的控制系統
跟更準確的軌道數據
一點運氣都不能依賴
要非常非常小心
就跟在臺灣走路一樣
為什麼一堆神經元放電
會產生「我」這種感覺
許多科學家提過各種假說
但德國的物理學家 Joachim Keppler 說
別想太難
其實你的大腦就是一台高級的量子收音機
這篇發表在《人類神經科學前沿》的研究
提出一個會讓神經學家跟物理學家
同喊 WT...
的理論
而這個 F 就是宇宙的「零點場」Zero-Point Field
大腦就是跟這個場進行量子連結
才產生意識的
零點場聽起來中二
但可是量子電動力學的核心
意思是說真空不空
裡面充滿了能量波動的海洋
而 Keppler 認為大腦
具體來說是皮層裡的「微柱」
裡面的關鍵成分麩胺酸 (Glutamate)
就是對接零點場的天線
麩胺酸我們很熟呀
就是味精的主要成分
但怎麼突然變成接受器了
因為它同時也是大腦中最豐富的神經傳導物質
在這個基礎上
Keppler 把意識的產生分成了「三部曲」
第一部是天線對頻
當神經突觸裡的麩胺酸濃度
達到一個臨界點時
會跟宇宙中頻率約 7.8 THz (太赫茲) 的零點場
發生「共振」
就像把收音機轉到「宇宙台」
大腦裡分子開始跟背景雜訊一起搖擺
第二部是領域展開
一旦連上線就會發生「相變」
這些麩胺酸分子會瞬間同步
形成一個「相干域」
這時候這個共振會被放大
頻率會從原本的 7.8 THz
轉移到 30 GHz 左右的微波頻段
對 微波
研究認為我們的大腦內部
會產生一個自帶的「柱內微波場」(ICMF)
所以最後就是第三部
微波控場
這個腦內微波功率不夠加熱
還好不夠
所以是拿來當「遙控器」的
研究指出這個微波場會精準地控制
神經元上的「電壓門控離子通道」
特別是鉀離子通道
能調節神經元何時興奮跟閉嘴
維持大腦的「興奮-抑制平衡」(E-I balance)
就像指揮家透過微波
指揮著幾百億個神經元演奏交響樂
而這場交響樂就是「意識」
聽到這邊如果你覺得根本是偽科學
那我也不能說錯
但這篇論文之所以值得介紹
是因為他接受否證
提出了一個非常有「萬磁王」風格的實驗
他建議可以透過
「遮蔽」大腦跟零點場的連結來驗證
講白了就是在老鼠大腦皮層裡
埋入特製導電金屬板
做出微型「法拉第籠」
這個金屬籠的設計
要剛好阻斷那個 7.8 THz 的頻率
理論上如果把這個籠子蓋上去
阻斷了宇宙的訊號
就算老鼠大腦結構完好
神經訊號也會亂掉
原本漂亮的「臨界動力學」特徵會消失
意識就會像關掉 Wifi 一樣斷線
以前我們笑戴錫箔帽的人是瘋子
但如果那個帽子的材質跟頻率弄對了
搞不好真的能把意識給「屏蔽」掉
起碼有一個科學家這麼認為
如果這理論是對的
作者認為那麻醉藥之所以有效
是因為它干擾了微管蛋白或離子通道
導致麩胺酸無法正常運作
讓你收不到訊號
而我們每個人
可能都只是宇宙這個巨大雲端伺服器的
一個登入端點
雖然這整個假說都「未經」驗證
但身為 YouTuber 當然接下來就是要推薦一款
最能幫我們連接宇宙零點場的...
蛤
還是沒有廠商找我們業配啊
那
我們來賣味精好了
以上就是本週的泛科學新聞
如果你喜歡今天的內容
或是對哪一則新聞想吐槽
歡迎在下面留言
也別忘了按讚、訂閱、開啟小鈴鐺
下週繼續發現這世界有多荒唐
如果你有拍到什麼
比友善的熊還可愛的背景圖
歡迎投稿喔
詳情請看下方的資訊欄
我們下週見